the donbass region in eastern ukraine
was home to a pre-war population of
around four million people and major
cities such as donetsk luhansk and
mariupol now in vladimir putin's
crosshairs
this businessman ran a local pizzeria
he's now fighting with ukraine's
volunteer defense force
in donbass we are a free people he says
but russia is trying to finish what it
started in 2014.
indeed parts of the donbass have been at
war for eight years after russia annexed
crimea pro-russian separatists tried to
take the donbass but around two-thirds
of the eastern regions remained under
ukrainian control producing a simmering
stalemate
just days before his invasion putin
signed decrees recognizing the
separatist republics of donetsk and
luhansk and promising to rescue their
russian-speaking populations from what
he called a genocide
asked whether putin is rescuing them
this russian-speaking resident scoffs
putin should retire he says he should
rescue his own people we are ukrainian
prior to the war he worked in a steel
factory like many in the dawn bass it's
very much uh kind of a rust belt of
ukraine it's an
economically very um very important
key region the region fell on hard times
in the 1990s but remained strategically
important if russian forces captured the
donbass and ker sun putin could control
a land bridge across ukraine's south
coast
and after the botched invasions of kiev
and other areas the donbass would also
give the russian president a much needed
victory
this is a huge importance for russia
not to show not to look as losers
and also to keep
ukraine under constant pressure and
control
may the ninth marks victory day in
russia commemorating the soviet defeat
of nazi germany the kremlin reportedly
wants to declare some kind of victory in
ukraine by that date but many military
experts believe a russian victory in the
donbass will take much longer and there
may be no victory day for russia at all
jeff sample global news toronto